you see this beautiful young man in my
left this is draymond Green right here
look at you you're fat he's a champion
this offseason it was the summer of
emoji we saw everyone tweeting emojis
out there to hold DeAndre Jordan thing
I'm going to ask you some questions
you've looked through you pick the emoji
that best suits a dress first one the
Golden State Warriors win the World
Championship
what is the emoji can I get some love to
the Golden State
Golden State Warriors all right second
one
draymond Green makes a fat contract what
is the other money got wings on him
Kyrie Irving says the Cavaliers would
have won if they were all healthy what's
the appropriate emotion so dream on what
are you saying with these emotions that
is very funny and this is self
explanatory fellas Monica um what was
your reaction emoji wise to the whole
DeAndre Jordan signing not signing in
the whole situation alright last one was
just watching what are the chances that
the Golden State Warriors win the
championship next scene
Trevon green he's emoji doubt and he's a
world champion